but as in person learning takes a step
forward many ccsd parents are really
frustrated their kids still cannot play
sports
with their school teams orco mana
joining us live from ccsd headquarters
where a protest is gathered behind you
orco and fully underway
that's right brian this let our kids
play protest has been going on for about
an hour now
here outside ccsd headquarters there are
dozens of parents and student athletes
holding signs and chanting as you can
see wanting to make their voices heard
now these folks are demanding
that school sports be allowed to resume
saying that some students
rely on sports scholarships and not
being able to play
is also affecting their mental health
it's been nearly a year since ccsd
postponed sports programs
cutting citing concerns over the
coronavirus the district announced that
it made this a difficult decision to
cancel fall sports
for the 2020-2021 school year but some
parents say it's not because of the
virus
they blame a lack of planning on ccsd's
part
we have states across the country that
have pulled this off safely
this can be done for the kids we need to
reverse
whatever mandate or directive exists
that is preventing this
collectively between the board of
trustees the governor
the superintendent we all need to get on
the same page
for the sake throw these kids a lifeline
for pete's sake
now as you can see there are some ccsd
police and metro police officers here
just to make sure that everything
remains safe and everything has been
safe and peaceful here
tonight and ccsd had initially said that
they might return fall sports in
february 2021
but it's unclear if that's still the
click the case right now there is
a board of trustees meeting happening
right now and several of the people at
the protest
have emailed in public comment to make
their voices
heard there as well reporting live from
ccsd headquarters tonight orco mana 8
news now